and people take no for an answer too
easily you want to do something
meaningful add some value I frankly
don't even care to talk to you if there
was no risk everybody would do it most
people do the traditional thing and get
to traditional places disrespecting
Authority some entrepreneurs do a really
good job of growing and we're going to
the details of story but they offered
seven billion dollars so 40 engineers
wasted three or four years of their life
he's an Indian American businessman
listed by Forbes magazine as a
billionaire he made his early fortune as
one of the cofounders of Sun
Microsystems he has an estimated net
worth of 1.5 billion dollars he's Vinod
Khosla and here are his top 10 rules for
success the funny thing is with enough
persistence most things that seem
impossible become possible I'm always
amazed at how often you can turn things
around and people take no for an answer
to easily
you know it's whether you're trying to
achieve a goal I get into business
school or my green card was the same way
I left the job that had sponsored me but
I still got my green card even though no
lawyer would take me I became my own
lawyer got my green card without working
for while I was at business school and I
did it perfectly legally I my strategy
there was if I couldn't convince
immigration I'd confuse them and I did
and they gave me my green card most of
the time when you start something you
want to do something meaningful and get
started and maybe smaller but you want
to keep innovating building on it one
step at a time and hopefully it becomes
much larger you know Amazon started with
just books now it's everything if you
look at Twitter or Facebook when they
started there were relatively small
things macaca was restrained too
that everybody on the Harvard campus not
seven billion people on the planet but
he kept expanding his vision so very
often when you start with an innovative
idea you don't know how big it is in
fact most of most of the really
innovative ideas have been very hard to
predict what's a large opportunity or a
small opportunity most people thought it
B&B would this be this very small nichy
little opportunity that a few people
would rent out their rooms and it'd be a
nice little business now it's huge
people thought ooh BRR would be this
limo service business it's now bigger
than all limos all taxis and maybe
replacing personal transportation so
it's not possible to always predict
everything and where things may go but
just because you can't predict where
things may go doesn't mean you shouldn't
try or you shouldn't start once you
start and you stay creative and
innovative and keep trying new things
things expand add some value there's a
true societal and business value
proposition there's a contribution I
find and I don't do this for reasons
other than the fact that you can't
long-term build a viable business
without making a real contribution most
people look at they can start a business
do an IPO make some money almost always
that leads to businesses that are round
trips what I call good they go up and go
down to build a durable business you
really have to focus on the value
proposition I am amazed at how few
people have a belief system what do they
actually believe it I and and yeah it's
okay to offend you guys 90 percent of
you will do what's expected of you as
opposed to what you want to do and you
know I even when I come to an event like
this say why am I here why would I even
bar
to take an hour of my valuable time no
it's true I I have to have a purpose
my goal is very simple if I can convert
one of you there's probably 400 500
people here if I can convert one of you
to follow your belief and have the guts
to follow your belief I'll have all
think of the hour as well spent but so I
will say what am I trying to do and why
I don't speak because somebody you know
will write nice things about it I always
sort of have a purpose but I have a
belief system and most people even
successful companies and have big beef
with fortune 500 CEOs I can talk about
that very little leadership there don't
have an internal compass of what they
believe in it's what do others expect
you know when I graduated I went into an
ocean nobody went into art no ship out
of the business school and people said
why wouldn't you work for Goldman or
McKinsey I said why would you like I
could fathom why you would want to do
that job
right I still can't by the way for those
of you going to those places and I'm
sure there's plenty I'm probably not the
right person to talk to you I frankly
don't even care to talk to you all of
you others I think there's something
wrong with anybody who fundamentally
wants to go work for one of the
consultants or the investment banks
today in this part that does they don't
understand how the world is going to
work in the future but my point again is
have a belief system follow that compass
and I'm overstating it a bit so there
may be some hope for those of you going
there but it's a lonely a little bit of
an exaggeration let me go back to this
issue of fortune 500 CEOs I've talked to
many over the years
if a New York Times writer writes an
article they want to change their
strategy they want to respond how silly
is that that some English major who's
never had a business job can determine
the strategy of a fortune 500 company
why because they care about what's
written not what they believe system is
do you know what the LAN must could say
to that writer go get a real job
all right what Jeff Bezos would say
that's leadership having a belief system
knowing what's driving you to do what
you do not you're fitting in to do
career enhancement or making it look
good to somebody else whether it's your
friends or to your boss or to
shareholders and frankly you look at all
the companies that are languishing in
the valley the older companies they
generally don't have a belief system
they're generally trying to meet some
quarterly target without saying here's
how we will be different and here's how
we'll do it
Apple did languish for 10-15 years and
then Steve Jobs came in with a point of
view and created the most valuable
company in the world he did irrational
things if you go back to January of 2007
January 1 everybody was saying nobody
wants a phone without a keyboard
nobody wants a phone that costs $6.99 I
can go on with the litany those were all
English majors writing articles I have
this beef against English majors not all
English majors are bad but the majority
of them at Stanford are undirected and
don't have a goal or a purpose sorry and
that's not to say among them there isn't
20% that are really good they just
didn't get the right guidance and ended
up in the wrong place
I like purposeful education when one is
starting it's hard to say what whether
it'll be successful or not if it's a
short success then there would be no
risk if there was no risk everybody
would do it and if everybody was doing
it it wouldn't be unique or innovative
so innovation fundamentally involves
risk-taking and risk-taking means
failure I like to say my willingness to
fail is what gives me the ability to
succeed and too many people just are not
willing to fail so they don't try
anything new I like to say you should
try and fail but not fail to try because
the people who fail to try fail to take
risk fail to do something attempt
something new are failing before they
start they just don't know it
but what transpired for me when I was
probably 15 was reading in the late 60s
about the founding of a company called
Intel Craig Barrett the CEO of Intel is
here and it developed as a role model
for me of what I wanted to do of course
at that stage of my life it seemed very
very far away but many years later and
I'll tell you later that I'm a big fan
of risk
I learned hang gliding and while
watching a movie about hang gliding I
saw this quote this dedication of the
movie and it went something like this
dedicated to those who dare to dream the
dreams and then are foolish enough to
try and make those dreams come true in
the operative word here is foolish
because unless you transcend what's
traditional and I think we've talked
about this earlier unless you go past
what's reasonable you're not going to
get someplace different most people do
the traditional thing and get to
traditional places
there is another way I think shaking
things up is an essential part of
entrepreneurship in sort of almost
challenging disrespecting Authority not
not being too confirming our essential
parts of entrepreneurship building a
team is the hardest thing for an
entrepreneur to do because very often
they don't know what they don't know
right they they know their area of
specialty really well but other areas
they think they understand but they
don't and every areas more complex and
more nuanced then it appears to somebody
you know - I see so many entrepreneurs
who think marketing is about a press
release or an advertising campaign it's
not it's much more nuanced and
sophisticated than that so team building
is very important some entrepreneurs do
a really good job of growing Larry Page
as an example
Mark Zuckerberg is an example of being
better at new functions as they come up
in and and and also they've done a
really good job of adding people who
they can learn these new areas from what
I find is some poor entrepreneurs assume
they know the answer and that's very
dangerous and others know they don't
know and they hire the people who they
can learn from but they can still apply
their entrepreneurial style in these new
areas sometimes it makes sense for the
entrepreneur to keep being CEO and
driving the whole vision usually that's
the best course but someone knows can't
think broadly enough to do that and they
can't grow fast enough you also have to
dare to be great I'll tell you one
little story one of the most successful
investments we made was a small company
called CERN we just started to sell
product you're doing fairly well we had
a half a million of revenue in 1990
Evon Cisco came said we'd like to buy
this company for three hundred million
dollars having invested three or four
million dollars for half the company
that'd be a pretty good investment and
yeah we had one other investment and I
said no deal because I believed in what
we were trying to do April came along
and somebody called me from Cisco and
said we'd like to offer seven hundred
million dollars and we at that point
with subsequent investments owned about
thirty five forty percent of the company
and I said no deal August came along and
won't go into the details of story but
they offered seven billion dollars we
did take the deal we put this sort of
slogan I prefer brutal honesty to
hypocritical politeness on our website
because it's a really disservice to
people you don't have to be offensive to
be honest when I don't like somebody I
can get offensive too but generally you
can be constructive and very honest and
I prefer that brutal honesty because it
serves a purpose the receiver can do
something about it if it's a
constructive criticism if you get for
the hypocritical politeness you might
lose a lot so again it's about having
enough confidence to say the other
person will eventually appreciate it and
that's logo good slogan came after I was
working on a company with another major
venture firm and I didn't believe their
plan would work
they had 45 50 million dollars in the
bank account so everybody was
comfortable too comfortable my view I
talked to the founders why it wouldn't
work what my concerns were the other VCS
agreed with me in the board meeting said
all these polite things you know so
40 engineers wasted three or four years
of their life because nobody was willing
to tell them the honest truth about what
they really thought I and I swore I
would never let anybody waste their life
at least give them the best advice I had
to give and tell them I may be wrong but
I'm not going to say something I don't
believe in I just want in and that's
extremely valuable to the other thing
but to be honest
look there are situations you keep it
offends people and I offend people often
but it helps them if they're really
introspective that's found oh by the way
in that company called me four years
later after after this company this
company got sold for three million
dollars for three and a half four years
later sad story and he called me a year
after that said I only want to work with
you on my next venture because I wish
somebody had told me thank you so much
for watching I made this video because
Levi's Mottola asked me to so there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of the top
ten rules hit you the hardest meant the
most to you leave it in the comments and
I'll join the discussion thank you so
much for watching continue to believe
and I'll see you soon
mark Nouriel light isn't all royalty
it's really hard failure feels pretty
bad you're hanging on by your knuckles
it's tough it's a life in which I like
to say it's really a roller coaster that
the highs are really high and the lows
are really love to be lonely it can be
difficult being through all of them
being through don't know how me next
month's payroll to why I'm the smartest
person in the world because everything's
gone right I've seen both emotions all
the time in the same soil so despite it
being up a hard life an entrepreneurial
life isn't easy it is a lot of fun
you're always stretching yourself you're
always learning something new you're
always pushing the boundaries of what
other people think is reasonable but and
I think most on noes are pretty
unreasonable because if there were only
doing reasonable things somebody else
would have done and outside two of my
favorite quotes on this George Bernard
Shaw said human progress depends on the
unreasonable man he should have said man
a woman but I'm being reproducing it
with fidelity Martin Luther King said
something similar he said human progress
depends on the socially maladjusted
that's what entrepreneurs are that's why
they do unreasonable tanks and
unreasonable things sorry I way past
your question but dobry just a stream of
consciousness and I talk a lot at the
voice sounds nice you know if you're
doing unreasonable things you're
stretching the balance if you're doing
reasonable things you're not stretching
the box you're not really taking risks
you're not going to do something
different I like to say not all hard
things are valuable but most heart the
most valuable things are hard but the
thing about entrepreneurship is it's not
about business it's not about investing
it's about having a desire to make a
difference most good for companies and I
suggest you look at every one of them I
built from passion for a region you have
a vision when I started my first company
dayz systems I looked at how engineers
used to design chips we said that was
silly and that was there was three of us
we just said we'll change that way and
it was the first CAD company really
there were a few others but none doing
quite what Daisy was doing as soon as we
started working on Daisy it realized
that engineers worked the wrong way all
engineers not just silicon engineers and
we started son because we wanted to
change that lose it I really believe to
this day to achieve anything you really
have to have passion for vision I have a
philosophy in life whatever I believe I
should make happen it's that simple and
if a customer is making a mistake
the customer isn't always right trust me
and if you want to do great products
don't listen to your customers by the
way lots of bad lessons in business
school I used to give a talk in the 80s
on why not to listen to your customers
and maybe somebody'll ask me a question
that story is in fact true there was a
signed contract with a competitor I
stayed in the lobby all day at 6 o'clock
in the evening and I'd taken a red-eye
out and I parked in Lobby I met with the
CEO of the company mostly because he
wanted me to go away by 9 o'clock he had
I'd convinced him to meet me in Chicago
with his team the next day because he
didn't want to be seen negotiating with
us the following morning the day after
at 5:00 a.m. we signed our handwritten
contract because I wouldn't let him live
oh this was the CEO of a big East Coast
company computer vision should we signed
a hand written contract and life was
good
the point is if you actually believe
something you try your best to make it
happen it doesn't always happen but it
happens most of the time most of the
business school entry story is also true
I actually learned that somebody had
dropped out that's why I showed up and
one of the nice ladies in the business
cool office put me in her living room -
her husband's chagrin and she was real
nice to me but things do work out if you
possess not always but I like to say
failure does not matter its success that
matters and nobody remembers what you
fail that